(surf music)
- [Lambert] There's so many
reasons why I do what I do.
I love surfing and I love helping people.
I think if everybody
found what they love to do
and what they were designed to do,
and used that gift to help others,
this world would look so different.
(bright music)
My name's Lambert Lo.
And I'm a surf instructor.
I was living in Hawaii, living the dream,
teaching surfing to
billionaires and celebrities.
And at the end of the day,
something was missing.
And I knew in my heart that
I needed to come back
to where it all started.
I grew up in California,
and the ocean was where I
felt the most connected.
I came back and started a non-profit
called The Mix Academy.
(lively music)
One of the things that
come out of The Mix Academy
is the surf school.
And I brought that gift of surfing
here with some of the people
that need the most smiles.
Push up on the side.
Stand up, go.
My current class consists
of a refugee from North Korea,
Nathan, a nine-year-old
who's visually impaired,
and Shannon, a veteran
going through alcoholism.
The School of the Misfits is a place
where you can belong.
On land, everyone looks at
us a little differently,
but when you're in the water,
the water washes all that off.
Woo!
Surfing, like life, is
full of ups and downs.
There's waves that are coming
and you can't stop that from coming.
The pain's gonna come.
What you can control is yourself
and how you're gonna react.
You can choose to paddle for it,
embrace it and adapt to it,
and enjoy the ride,
or this wave's gonna come
and it's gonna knock you out
and it's gonna wipe you out.
Catching the wave is a great feeling,
helping others catch their first wave
is a greater feeling.
To watch that smile just ear to ear,
and knowing that, man, that's
gonna change someone's life.